OOoh here we go, oh I found you. Ah I found...
Oh hello what the fuck are you? What are you doing here?
get the fuck out of here! There it is ok got it! Yesss!
Yess YAASSS! Oh there was anoother waay
oh there was a way at the boottom OHOKAY
Alright I got it though hoha MOOohahah MOOOO HAHAha
Hello everybody and my name is Markiplier and welcome back to subnautica.
Now things got a little out of hand the last episode I will readily admit,
But I just went down there in the dead of night
to not only get my Seamoth back
but also get the last piece of the
Nuclear Reactor fragment so that I can
build that in my base but now I don't
want to waste any of you more, *weird mouth noises*
*screaming*
*more noises* I can't talk!  Now I don't want to waste any more
of you guys time so what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to speed through getting
all of the materials necessary to not
only build this nuclear reactor but also
provided me with enough titanium such
that I will not be such an idiot anymore
and I will not go down to the depths and
get what I don't have with what I don't
need where I don't need to go. Understand?
So I'm going to get into the future
riiiiiiiiiiiiiiight NOOooooowwwwww
When in reality I have to FAAarrmm for
a whiiiiiile
it's fucking BUUUuullll SHIiittttt
Oookaayyy OKAAYy OKAY!!!!
Welcome back one in all it is time again
To get into Subnautica and go back down
into the depths and hopefully never ever
ever ever return ever again
Now I don't know if that's true but all
I know is that I've got an inventory
full of titanium and enough materials to
be able to build a Nuclear Reactor and
hopefully with a Nuclear Reactor we'll be
able to use
Nuclear energy to power all of our Nuclear
needs. So once I get this and stop being
such a fool and I don't want to be a
fool I want to be better than a FOOL
I want to be an above-average Fool *Clears throat*
I know that we can get down and yes I, I
I do know, I do know, I do know, about the fact
that I did not see thee Degasi base it
was right in front of me apparently I
was being too much of a big bubble
blowed biaatch to be able to see it
I'm just trying to get one more piece of
led before I get over there. There we go
perfect got it everything's falling up
my way everything's coming up Markiplier
here, so now that I got that OH also I'm, I'm almost dead
So that's,
that's another FACT. But now that I got that I have
enough material to be able to go down
here get in my base again fix it all up
nice and tight *kisses*  get it right and
tight and then be able to build a
Nuclear Reactor which I need to build
another room for that and ALSO not to
forget that I need to put the locker
names on there now unfortunately I
didn't save the list of names I'm going
to go back and get the name from the
last episode that I did put them up
there, but for now I have put this off
for too long I'm going to do it
immedi-- I don't quarts
FFFFFUUUUCK  Okay you know what that's fine
It's okay, I know the ominous music is kind of
coincided with my own foolishness but
it's ok it's alright
Ook so I can build more lockers now
that's not, that's not correct to
direction that isn't, that's weird
ok Imma, Imma go with that as being
alright and not worry about it
yeah okay alright okay, you know what it is
alright FUCK what do I not have I'm OUT OF
POWER for my builder!? I don't even know
that thing could run out of power!?
well I don't have enough to make a
battery! I'm all out of batteries nooOOOOO
OH NOOooOOoo
OHH come on there's no acid mushrooms
down here! I don't have a battery!! fuck
I am a goddamn fool I can't build anything
I can't even build a battery
charger! It's out of battery who would have thought that?!?
I didn't think of THAT!!
did anybody think of that?!? No one thought
of that!?! No one saw that coming..
Fuck I.. I didn't expect this in any
capacity
I apologi--hehe-gize-ha I apologize I'm just a
bloody fool that's what I am I'm a gosh fool I am, I am, YEs I AM
SOoo.. Okay *incoherent* Lets gooo...
Oh wait before I do that, what I can do to be smart
Fuck'in why would you just ram into that!?!
yeah that's what you're supposed to do
not ram into the pressure barrier that
created by that pressure fuck.. Whatever
Seamoth, isn't there like a common module storage
module yeah I think my Seamoth baby needs
a storage module
I'll go get more titanium while I'm
doing this FUCK I can't believe this!?!?
BULLSHIT
I can't believe this bullshiiiat!
So Imma, Imma just do this because I need it
*Bad European accent* 'Cause why not?It does not have many upgrades
*accent* So might as well put the storage module
*accent* on it and then be able to take it out and
*accent* I will be fucking  back, with even more
titanium and a fresh baaattery
FUUCK, see in a bit I suppose this is
what I promised, this is what I promised
this is what I promised, no cheating
it's the -RAW EXPERIENCE- of the game!
And that's what makes it fuNN!!
Well I'm hav'in FuNN... Alll right Al'igh
I got it, I got everything! My storage
module is full to bursting it's swollen
with pride
it's SWOL (af) with acid mushroom mostly and
a little bit of titanium salvage I've
got everything that I need and we're
only what 30 minutes into this recording
FINE that means more saved time for you
because we are going down into see the Dagasi
no matter what I'm accomplishing
that I just be know I was going to run
out of power but the good thing is I've
got ooodels and caboodles of more titanium
so that means I shouldn't run out for a
long time I don't know how many more
things that could possibly build out of
this son of a bitch but I've got the
materials necessary to do it and that is
very important to know I've got what I
need to make my life easier and then go
home and then go see what's up with the
last place of the Degasi and finally put
some goddamn names on the goddamn
lockers, so let's do all that. Alright
let me put some of this crap back
in it boop boop, boop-a-te-boop. I gotta make me up battery I
don't have the battery materials because
I put it back in here like an idiot *doof*
doot-a-lee-doot let's unloaded all right got that
let's build a fuck'in battery and then we
gotta build a battery charge because I've
had the schematic for the battery
charger forever and I've just been
wasting battery hither and tither
okay, BOOM.. Oh fuck I have to actually do it
BOOM.. Fuck'in what?!? What am I out of, what!?! Ooh I put
away my titian-gug-AHHH, alright
HUURAHH, there finally ah-oh that took a while
hang on let me save on this one. ALRIGHT
OKAY alright the first name i'm gonna
put is everybody all of you guys, every
single one of YOU out there watching
right NOW is on this locker. Because not
only was that last time that everybody
told me something that I should have
known but I was too stupid to notice but
now everybody said I MISSED THE HIDDEN
BASE because Imma dummy haha I am that's
me that's me I'm a dummy on the big old
dummy-do and I couldn't see it when it
was right in front of my face because I
was scared I was too busy shitting my
pants to be able to see a base in front
of me so congratulations everybody
you're now on a locker
But also M.A.DGAME for uhh mad gaming, said "This is
probably the most scared and stressed at
a game I've seen you since Vanish. Your
characters tombstone will be at the
bottom of the ocean etched with needs..
needed more titanium." Well I've solved
that problem now because I've got so
much titanium but I know I'll run out,
and thank you for being here all the way
back since the Vanish days. Next up is
JessicaH for Jessica Hudson who said "I've
never played Subnautica but I'm into
horror movies so you constantly shitting
yourself because of it makes me want to
buy it."
Well if you hate the ocean like I do
then maybe this game is not for you
because otherwise I wouldn't be playing
this game because MY GOD, it's fucking
terrifying literally all the time
there is not one moment when this game
is not terrifying to me it goes halfway
in between being like" Oh that's so cool"
too *screams* OH! OH GOD, underwater ocean monsters
because that's all there is.
Anyway I'm getting rid of all the
salvage that I got them turning it into
delicious titanium trying to remember not to
turn it into a god damn ingot like an
idiot would, which is something that I've
done before, but I've got enough ingots
to be able to do what I need to doooo
Ha-boosh-ki, okay so that's all my ssalvage if I put
that, I'll make this like the titanium
locker. Like the Hurt Locker but much
less fun not the Hurt Locker was fun
anyway. You know I'm gonna take all that
back I have no idea what I'm talking
about so *deleted*  Okay and you may be thinking
to yourself "Oh that's a lot of titanium
that you got there Mark, you're doing
pretty well for yourself!"
Well haha joke's on you that's not even
close to all the titanium that I got to
keep that power cell on me get rid of this, keep the lube ~okay ;)~
dump the ion crystals, dump these bad
batteries, flashlight, acid mushrooms uhg sure
ahh thats full, okay that good. Boop boop de Boooo, not
water and need that right now *singing*
Okay, then I've got EVEN more
WHAT?! Stealth titanium holy shit mark
you got it you got it in the bag
WOAH a whole full storage module of ultimate
titanium and I didn't fucking cheat at
neither! Well I got a headache but I got
it
+1, +1 extra titanium, but unfortunately I do
need some titanium so I'm going to keep some on
me, because I am going to.. I probably need
more than that *mouth noises* I'm
going to go out there I'm going to brave
the horrible horrible-horribleness that is the
ocean..Why is this so.. why is this so low? Why is this one low?
Is that low? It doesn't look low seems like it might
be low, ahh whatever
just make this because I know the base
isn't doing too good in structural
integrity so might as well get a little
more before we make it another
attachment on it, but I'm gonna make this
one multi-purpose room mooahh, no
can't build there,  yeah-yeah-yeah-yeah Karen I got
it I got it you're always worrying about
me,
have I evER EVER gotten myself into
trouble and not been able to get out of
it?!
EVVERR have I oh, every time? Oh literally
always? Oh well there must be some Ooh no
no no never no I've never once been
able to take myself out of the situation I've got into
but at least I've got the necessary
materials to build, a Nuclear Reactor
you know one of these little old things, oh it's over
here you know what these delightful
monstrosities it's going to pump my
entire base full of ur-an-ium...
and-and-and-annnnd!! Sha-boosk-i  Okay, got it
exercise caution when handling
radioactive materials in the event
of exposure there's a risk that the data
on your PDA recording the circumstances
of your death will be permanently erased Hmm-mmmm
OH okay is that good or bad maybe nobody
should know that I was here and there
was doing horrible things. So I need to
gettt, I need to gettt, you know it's
odd that I have a nuclear reactor in
here when the nuclear reactor killed the
vast majority of my fellow survivors
here in the deep, dark, ocean.
Oh well not my.. *jumpcut* I just need to be
able to get a nuclear rod for that thing
and the only thing that I don't have in
that regard is the uranium, I have one
more led I was sure to get that before I
came back but, all that is going to have
to wait. I know I can find uranium down
where the Degasi is but I need to go
down there first now I've got enough
food
I've got health, I've got water, I don't
have any of those spare things on me
I.. I meant to build a filtration system
but I want to..*computer male voice* ..I want
to wait until I actually have, you know
enough power and and I'm pulling double
duty here because I'm going to go down
into the depths and I'm gonna go back go
back into place that I hate, Imma go back, I
gotta go back why do I have to go
back? Where even was it? Not here
apparently.. ahh-geese, ahh-geese Scoob
Yep, see you when I see you Karen, take care
of the base for me while I'm gone, stay safe
I suppose
oh wait I think I see it,  I think I see
it, no.. yeah I do, I do it's right in front
of me
AHHHhhhh AHHhhhh nope that's a rock ai-yai-yai
warper incoming, holy shit Ahhhh- AHHHH!!! FUCKING
fuck, Oh God I hate you
oh I've been told that you're not lethal
OOooo you still Fuck'in terrifying, you are, okay
alright, so it's got to be here
OOOOoo I see it! I see it! I see it!  AHHhh I see it! It's
right in front of my face it was easy to
miss because I was really not happy with
where I was
Oh, oh god, oh god, yes.. They really went
all out with this one ha. Oh fuck you
Ooh fuck that. AHHHH-ahh-ahhh what are you doing? What are you do'in? AHHHH
AHHHHHHHHH-ahhhh-ahhh-ah Okay alright leave me alone, noo
FUCK'IN-DON'T!!! Leave me the fuck alone!!
I was told you were non-lethal, EEAAHHHH *noises*
Okay so I gotta get in there. There's still a PDA there
whole bunch of stuff in there that I
need.. Ooh boy, OOOhh boi, Ooh bo--I WILL FUCK'IN BEAT
THE SHIT OUT OF YOU!!! You wanna fuck'in fight bruh!!??
I'LL BEAT THE SHIT OUT OF YOU!!!!
Yeah, you better run.. Biiaatch, okay I think I
showed him
yeah I'm not to be trifled with.. *jumpcut*
Okay, there is, there are, there was, right here
Scanner Room, do I have that? I already have that. I
don't need that I just need to get the
fuck in here. Where am I gonna do that? Ei-Yai-Yai, I need oxygen first.
No, don't access the upgrades!! Okay,
alright,  get in here, get in, get in, get in, get in, get in-n-n-n-n-n,
Get the fuck out of my way scanner room, we don't need you here!
Okay we got a PDA, here, got the PDA Ooo I see
them outside!! Ooh coffee vending machine?!?
Okay?! How do they have that?!? Bottle of Booze??
Okay so there's a way up, I know that
there's a way up, how do I get up?
Ahh, through this hole? AHHH I don't like the sound of that.. YA-AHHHHH!! Fucking, fuck you!
OOooh-oooh I know you can't hurt me but oooooo
Woah, he-woah
Oh fuck off, you want to fuck on me?!?  HUH!!
I will FUCK you up
I will fuck you up, I will FUCK you up, GET the
fuck out of here
fuck you up! HUH!!  I'll punch in your jelly
head, how do you like that you like it i
got not gonna fuck you up around fucking
dead are we are we dad with that is
twitching bad corpse that's right get
the fuck out of here
I got tried to message me top bull horn
holes
that's what the ball you get my ass
things attached to the open okay an
aquarium in their legs okay nothing in
there okay i can go down but let me
check all the observatories and whatnot
who another PDA here i'm gonna i'm gonna
look at all these in a bit when they
have more time to think about it
another one there lab equipment that
story's full orange artifact Orange
County Parks that's weird
do i need this lab equipment why would
they need this
don't be bad about taking anyway I guess
get a retraction i already have that ok
i think that absolutely everything
second is like removal i do not see
anything else besides now that's nothing
there's nothing in there i got the pda's
I've got everything I need
let's get the flock out of here get the
fuck outta here okay i believe the exit
is this way
yeah we find out i can beat the shit out
of those guys with my wicked luxe my
haymakers were covered in hot and happy
I fucking hate that please like you guys
you guys may have some understanding
that i hate the ocean but i have learned
in my time and sub nautica especially
being of the mind where I'm just here
alone and I know it's the game but I
fucking I can't feel I cannot deal with
that I hate it I fucking hated not
exaggeration not a joke not fucking it's
just use
it's not fun not fun down there not fun
even if I can beat the shit out of a
crab squid which is what that is home
we are home baby i'm home care
oh fuck ok so I've got lab equipment for
some reason Jessica can you hold onto
this for me and I've got a orange
artifact I've never seen the orange
artifact before I didn't meet one
ok so the gossip blogs databank not logs
bank data download the gauzy survivors
logs seven stop it both of you were sick
what how you been coughing right feeling
itchy
yeah suit biometrics would have worn
this it's something new
spit it out then we're gonna throw up
her insides dissolve into slime what I
don't know if I can isolate the bacteria
in our blood that I could test its
effect on our life specimens and if it
turns them inside out you got a fixture
that
not this time know you have my full face
son sound of hats closing cpu Margaret
made it has boarded the habitat
what are you so happy about made a say
kid about you something that'll of Ivan
coat at home on the back of the sub you
killed it
you still breathing out about to finish
the job pass me that hardened knife
are you out of your mind you brought
that thing here with others cuff you
rather it got curious and came of its
own accord or got messed up and dragged
here when we get off this planet
i'm going to drag you through every
Court in the damn Empire oh so it's
sheets the kidneys specimens for his
research
I'm the one bringing home our teller
teller on right hydration google you're
both wrong Margaret I can't find out how
these creatures resistant bacteria if
you kill them all the pump them full of
transfuse serums it often obliged and
coming in alive what do you expect
don't speak to him like that father the
outcomes no better if we hold up in here
and don't go outside we have to find a
middle way there's no compromise not
while she's on my sea bass your seat
base
I'm going outside art torgul has left
the habit
artist dangerous damn boy I know you can
hear me
chief keef get off the radio put on your
helmet what grace sound of habitat
rupturing and water pouring in
so they got attacked by a Leviathan they
did survive a long time with the disease
but they in the end got attacked by a
Leviathan probably could because
Margaret fucking this broad one home
why did you do that okay but I need to
make uranium I got a ton of that I've
got a ton of that actually I've got more
in here
I only need the one right now but I just
want to get this stuff out of here
because you do because i can
okay thank you mr. Fisher you are good
and drew great men of you okay
advanced materials uranium I'm gonna
make a uranium rod just make sure I
didn't jump anymore let in here i got
was led ok can I make another one
nope it's not in food uranium rod is not
needed and then BAM okay so I got to so
there's a maximum before that you can
put in but now that I have this I should
this should work right just yeah yeah
yeah yeah look at that power
I mean it doesn't look like it's doing a
whole lot of the power shooting up
yeah yeah I got power
oh I've got so much power and that means
that i can make a water filtration
system that separates water and salts
with that right bear got plenty of water
it's going to make water up for me I'm
gonna have plenty of water to go I'm
gonna be good
I'm gonna be so good to be the best
how long is this going to the boomerang
birds sitting in my mic mr. Fisher's
inventory but this is good this is good
because now that I've got more than
enough power to offset that and then
this only has enough space so it's not
going to go on forever just making
endlessly going to make just enough so
that i can do that all i can make one
more uranium rod i can make women get
lots of power and Boop
ok got that that's going to make me up
some water real quick and then
hi pookie ok yes
oh that's so good that's so good i've
got so much power
yeah i doing it I'm doing it okay so
anyway it's been a bit of a long haul
for this episode for me anyway you guys
are processing the accelerated version
of it but it's been a long haul for me
and I managed to do it so I'm very happy
with where we are right now I'm hoping
this instance we water before I run out
of water but if I need more water i'll
just go eat some fruit i suppose but
either way thank you everybody so much
for watching thank you for believing in
me this whole time which i'm sure you
all did without a doubt in your mind
about my survival chances
yeah thank you Karen so thank you
everybody so much for watching keep the
comments flowing I now have the means
with which to make lockers again and as
I make them i'm going to write in names
and filling some of the names that I mr.
must thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see YOU...
the next video.
Buh-Bye!